the mystery of time travel
has been solved humankind has built a
machine
that can move through time you can go
back in the past and witness
any event in history or you can uncover
the mysteries of the future
but only one person can make the journey
and you're going to be the first person
to
travel through time get ready for a trip
like never before because where we're
going
we don't need roads here's how to
survive
time travel
today time travel technology doesn't
exist
but there are many theories that explain
how it could be possible
according to einstein's theory of
relativity as you approach the speed of
light
time will slow down for you relative to
the rest of the world
and the theory also says that gravity
bends time
the stronger gravity is the slower time
will move
general relativity also suggests the
existence of wormholes
these are passages through space-time
that can span billions of light years
what if we could build a machine that
could approach the speed of light
travel near a black hole with its
immense gravity
or move through a wormhole why should
you
not travel backwards in time and why
might you want to travel somewhere
as empty as possible step one
be prepared for anything
even though you can travel through time
it'll be hard to know what lurks on the
other side
be prepared for any type of danger how
much do you know about where
and when you're traveling to the amount
of oxygen in the atmosphere is
constantly changing
if you arrive somewhere and the oxygen
levels are too different than what
you're used to
it could be hard to breathe you might
want to bring a portable oxygen
concentrator for your trip
another thing you'll want to consider
are diseases and illnesses
you could be exposed to a slew of
foreign viruses that existed in that
time period
catching a disease is bad enough don't
catch one in another time period
figure out which diseases you might
encounter learn about the proper
precautions you'll need to take
and if you want to be really cautious
about the illnesses you might face
wear a suit no not the suit you'd wear
to work
you're not time traveling to your next
interview a hazmat suit can help to
protect you from airborne diseases
okay you're suited up and the machine's
booting up
is there anything that you shouldn't do
before you step in
step two don't travel back in time
i know it might be tempting to go back
in time to see the dinosaurs or to fix a
mistake that you made in the past
but by doing so you create time
paradoxes
altering the past could drastically
change our current timeline
even just being in the past and not
doing anything
might change the present and in the
worst case scenario
triggering a chain of events could
affect your past relatives
this could stop your grandparents or
parents from ever meeting
and as a result prevent you from being
born
you'd face a fate worse than not
surviving
you'd cease to exist but traveling
forward in time is also possible
technically the astronauts aboard the
international space station
are living in the future right now this
is because they're constantly moving
at eight kilometers per second or five
miles per second
because of time dilation the astronauts
are about 13 milliseconds in the future
compared to us oxygen concentrator and
hazmat suit
check don't travel to the past check
looks like you're prepared to go on our
trip to the future
step three look out for obstacles
now that we've figured out when you
should time travel to it's also
important to know
where will you end up in the same spot
or will you end up somewhere
completely different are you traveling
through a wormhole
or re-materializing into another time
trust me when i say
that you want to go somewhere open and
empty
when your body reintegrates whatever's
occupying the space
could mix in with you objects bugs or
even other people might get stuck inside
your body
a better way of time traveling could be
with an enclosure that protects you from
the environment
that way you don't materialize somewhere
that you wouldn't want to be
you've plotted your course the machine
revs up and in a blinding flash
you're in the future everything around
you has changed
but there's something wrong there's
nobody around
not a soul in sight your machine is gone
there's no turning back you're stuck in
the future
and you're the last person on earth but
don't lose hope we'll show you what to
do on how to survive